[Music]
casey
is with us in case he's in uh texas
hi casey welcome to the dave ramsey show
hi dave hi dr deloney thanks so much for
having me
sure what's up so i recently got engaged
um and my fiance and i are looking at
buying or building a house in an up and
coming area here in austin
um but throughout this process there
have been some red flags that have been
raised and now i'm just kind of trying
to figure out what to do
and what i should do from a relationship
standpoint and a financial standpoint
okay what kind of red flags so
we had had some discussions while we
were dating
about finances and it seems that they
were sugar coated a bit
um and so
basically when we started having
financial conversations
um i had some concerns and i i talked to
my parents my parents are awesome and
for my birthday got me financial peace
university
so i got on the debt snowball bandwagon
and within the next six weeks i'll have
paid off all of my debt and be
completely debt free
but he didn't really get on that
bandwagon with me and
it turns out after we got engaged that
his debt is about double
what i thought it was um so he has about
a hundred thousand dollars in debt
and i think just our views of finances
our views of debt are very different
and so that that's our my primary red
flag is it different because
you thought it or is it different
because he lied to you
i think a little bit of both so i
i think you know i um getting out of
debt is
a huge deal for me i'm so excited i you
know i have a phd
i had a lot of debt out of getting out
of my doctoral program
um and so now i'm finally there i taste
it i taste the freedom
and i think his the way he accrued his
debt was in his 20s we're both we're
older now we're both 36
um and he accrued it through traveling
and backpacking and playing
and so i think and and he has about 44
000
student loans as well so it wasn't all
fun and games
but um you know i think there's just a
fundamental difference in the way we
think about finances and
yes um just the fact that he wasn't
transparent um
is an absolute issue as well okay so
it may be because he maybe i'll i'll cut
him a little slack it's possible with a
guy like this he wasn't transparent
because it just doesn't matter to him i
think that's a lot of the case i don't
think he overtly lied
um he had malice or something here
so uh have you guys set a date for your
marriage
we had set a date for february and now
um you know we've been going through the
picking out options for the building the
house and stuff and it's been very
obvious that he wants very high-end
materials i mean there's an expectation
that i'll put down
20 of the down payment out of my money
so for me
i'm just i put it on hold so put the
house on hold and the marriage on hold
uh we put the marriage on hold and i'm
not sure what i want to do about the
house right now
okay well i mean the house would be
easier and more important to put on hold
not more important but i mean that
should have been on hold before the
marriage is put on hold
so uh because it's revealing the other
stuff in my opinion so yeah
okay so uh
john jump in here yeah i want to i want
to start there with the house
um don't continue buying a house with
somebody that now you're
wondering if you're going to spend time
with them for the rest of your life
because
going into a joint home purchase is
going to complicate that separation down
the road
significantly the second thing is is
going back what dave said
i think you need to sit down and be
direct with him about what your values
are and about your
confusion or frustration with him having
about twice the debt that he had
and your expectations for moving forward
as a couple it doesn't sound like you
all have dreamed about what something's
going to look like because you're
building a house and you still
aren't fully formed there so you come
trying to play house a little bit play
dating
a little bit think about marriage a
little bit and you got to get these
priorities in order
yeah the um the thing is this when i
first started teaching this stuff casey
um and you can share this with him as
well um i thought i was just teaching
people to get on a budget
and i was forcing couples that were
married
from a practical standpoint it's just
much easier tactically to handle money
when you have one account
and you have one budget and you're both
working together it's just easier
and what i didn't realize was i was
forcing them to dream
together i was forcing them to face
their fears together
i was forcing them to do life together
and when you've got different views of
handling money
it's not the money that matters the
money doesn't matter
but what it's exposing is is that you
value different things
you know you have a different dream a
different way of looking at the future
or you look at the future he doesn't or
vice versa
and so what what's revealing here is
that um your values are are
substantially different and that's
reflected in
the money and so you get comfort from
uh you know being out of debt and saving
money he doesn't even address the issue
he's
the ultimate free spirit backpacking
through europe and running up
debt you know and that's there's nothing
evil about that that's just a
that's one story of people's journey how
they get there
but then the point is if you're going to
be married to someone
uh you've got to be able to
uh give and take between the two of you
and say okay
we as a couple are going to develop a
money philosophy uh and we're going to
develop
a philosophy on how we deal with parents
and we're going to develop a philosophy
on how we deal with kids and we're going
to develop a philosophy on how we deal
with religion
and if you don't do that you're not
going to succeed in your marriage
all the data points in marriage
statistics and divorce statistics tell
us this
and so um and 30 years of sitting at
this desk
i've observed it time and time again so
i think this is salvageable
absolutely i do but i think it's going
to require some strong
handed pre-marriage counseling that
forces both of you him to get a little
bit more responsible and you to lighten
up a little bit
and it forces both of you to the table
and go this is what i
value and if you are going to completely
poop on it we're not supposed to be
together
and casey can i tell you somewhere where
i heard
you speak where i think you could start
with your own heart
is it sounds like a part of you thinks
that the debt you accrued
was good debt because it was going
towards school
you're fancy now you're a doctor you're
rocking the world
and his debt was not good that so
there's all there's this
he was the irresponsible backpack right
so when you're judging him when you're
already coming to the table as though
hey i've made better choices than you
you've made i want you to
like yeah approach him on equal measure
you're both going to the same
relationship you got stuff you're going
to bring into it in your backpack he's
going to bring stuff in his
and you got to start an equal footing
and decide where you want to go and
don't build a house or buy a house until
you've been married at least a year
absolutely at least a year
just pause that whole thing dump the
house stop the house deal completely
and do that yeah and you know take the
time and do pre-marriage counseling by
the way
again there's all kinds of data that
says if you do
in-depth pre-marriage counseling you
have an
80 percent more likely chance of having
a successful marriage that doesn't end
divorce
because what happens is they'll run a
good
in-depth coach like that a counselor
will end your relationship
before a marriage or they'll bring you
together
and your marriage is going to be healthy
and you learn communication tools and
give and take
and you lighten up and he series is up
or whatever the right phrase is he gets
you know he gets the more response
grows up grows up and you come together
and that's what can happen it can be a
really useful process